were you angry when you first got your
diagnosis like I would be this is not
supposed to happen to me I'm on a major
role in my career I've got a great wife
I got a family this just doesn't happen
to me yeah I had that reaction I had
that like let me come back in the room
and and deal with the fact that Michael
Fox that this isn't happening to me that
I'm not an 85y old man right and the way
that he put it too he told me I was at
Parkinson's so I'm dealing with that and
then he said but don't worry you have
another 10 good years left to work and I
I was 29 years old right unbelievable W
so so and that's and that was 20 years
ago so some people were angry you didn't
tell people right away everyone had
judgments to make I don't know why it
was really strange because yeah
everybody had an opinion about it and
and and and that kind of really helped
me because I realized how bullshitty
that was right that the only opinion
about it that mattered was me yeah and
and and it was funny too cuz cuz I
testified in front of Congress about
funding for Parkinson's really early on
and I didn't take my medication CU I
wanted them to see what it does what it
does to to person and and then a lot of
people had opinions about that how dare
he not take his medication and I thought
how dare I not take my medication what
the [__] yeah I mean what's it to them
it was a strange time cuz like I said
the guy told me I had 10 years left to
work and it was like being stuck in the
middle of the road with cement feet and
a bus is coming and you don't know when
it's coming and you don't you can hear
it but you don't know when it'll be
there and you know how hard it'll hit
did you go into therapy right away I'm
talking about the Psychotherapy a couple
couple years later I did that you waited
a couple of years my first reaction to
it was to start drinking heavily did you
I yeah I I started uh what's heavily I
used to drink to party but then I was
drinking now I was drinking alone and
just drinking every day every day so you
were self-medicating yeah then I quit
that and then how did you quit it did
you go to AA yeah once I did that then
there was about a year of like a KN
fight in a closet where I just didn't
have my tools to deal with it but then
then after that then I went into therapy
and and it all started to get really
clear to me how did it get clear like
hey this isn't a death sentence and I
can have a life take one day at a time
and then things started to really turn
the other way then it it got my my my my
marriage got great because all of a
sudden you realize wow this person
really has my back she's like with me
exactly yeah like I really appreciate
her for the maybe the first time and
people have this image of her that that
she's like this rock and she's not she's
not like this stoic Champion she's like
this cool chick who like could have
bolted but she didn't I think that's
what people don't get about
relationships if you have a woman who
really cares about you and loves you
yeah it there's nothing better than that
and laughs are your jokes the 19th time
around we make the same joke and Tracy
says I'm on a loop it's getting shorter
sex still good sex is great that that
doesn't never get affected no that's I
mean the only thing about sex is is
deciding who's going to be the agent of
motion yeah who's moving faster you get
some new moves I guess yeah and what
about the kids are they going to be do
that again I I can't do it again that
just happened that was spontaneous that
just that just
happened